if Jennifer sulke got her way and we had
a Stargate movie before a new series
how would that look
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
now this is going to be more of a rambly
video I'm gonna just tell you how I feel
about the concept or the prospect of a
new Stargate movie uh what that could
potentially look like and my thoughts
about it so I mean the way I see it
there are one of two possibilities that
could happen the first possibility is
with a new movie it's going to be kind
of like a hard reboot it's going to
basically continue on from where the
original movie left off the second
option would be a continuation so
everything that happened in Stargate sg1
Stargate Universe Target Atlantis it all
happened
and anything that happens in the new
movie is a continuation of that
so let's dive into those two
possibilities because the very first
possibility that I mentioned would be
the pro the concept of a hard reboot and
that's something that I'm not on board
with and I know a lot of you guys who
watching this video now are going to be
down in the comment section down below
because I know hard reboots no hard
reboots and it's something I completely
agree with you on
we we don't need a reboot not enough
time has passed from when Stargate left
our screens in 2011 to now to Warrant
having a hard reboot you can continue
the story yes you're going to have new
actors yes you're gonna have new stories
but you can bring in the old characters
as cameos you can have them be special
guests and basically acknowledge the
fact that the entirety of the 17 Seasons
that have come before whatever comes now
would have happened and that's
that's what I want I want something that
will continue what has already happened
but let's for example say
they do a hard reboot okay
if they were to do a hard reboot it was
to continue on from where the original
1994 movie left off I can see two
possibilities with this they would
either do a hard reboot ish where they
would essentially
draw on what had happened in sg1
and bring in little aspects of that
story into the new movie
which is which is an ideal I think that
would be the ideal of the two scenarios
I'm going to put forward the second
scenario would be if they continued
where with what role in American Dean
devlin's original movie plans were now
if you don't already know the original
plans for this Stargate movie were to be
a Trilogy and this was something that
was actually green lit probably about
five years ago but it never came to
fruition
for whatever reason it didn't happen and
I'm quite thankful it didn't but
essentially the original trilogy That
was supposed to happen was we had the
original
1994 movie that happened we saw that
Happy Days
but in the second movie they would go to
a second address and they would
essentially only be three addresses that
the gate could go to there wasn't
thousands and thousands of addresses
across the Mercury Galaxy and then more
in the Pegasus Galaxy it was three
addresses leading to different parts of
the universe because really what
happened in the original movie is they
went to a different galaxy and that's
something that they changed in sg1 which
I'm quite thankful that they did
because they were in they were within
the local Galaxy which was quite nice
but if they were to go
to the second address in the second
movie it would have been a Mayan planet
and it would have centered around Mayan
mythology and that's pretty much all we
know the third movie would have been
something very similar but it would have
tied up the Egyptian the the Mayan
mythology and then something else from
Earth's mythology into one neat little
ball and would have like given us like
the meaning of life kind of
um
answers that we need
as humans that's essentially what the
original trilogy was going to be and if
they were to do a hard reboot with this
new movie that's a possibility that they
could go down and that's something I'm
not I'm not on board with I would much
rather if they did a hard reboot that
they would essentially just draw an
inspiration from what happened in sg1
stock Atlantis not necessarily
acknowledging that they happen but doing
them again just in more interesting and
fresh new ways so some of the things
that we're more accustomed to like the
dial Home device
um the gdos that they used I mean the
ships attack vessels the Asgard if they
just bring in little elements of what
happened in sg1 into a new movie and
then the following series assuming it's
going to be a continuation of what the
movie has
that's okay with me
but it's not the most ideal situation or
my it's not the most ideal scenario for
me at all
now the second option outside of a hard
reboot movie would be a movie that
continues what has already happened a
movie that acknowledges the 17 Seasons
that came before it and acknowledges all
the characters and the stories and
everything that happened and continues
from the point we left off
not necessarily from the point we left
off so the last time we saw anything to
do with Stargate it was Eli on the ship
of Destiny on the bridge of Destiny
looking out as everyone else was in
stasis and he was drifting into the into
the vast nothingness in between galaxies
now you don't necessarily have to start
at that point But continuing
in that timeline essentially that's what
I would really really like
the problem that I can see with a
continuation however is how would they
do it in a way that respects what's came
before it
and also brings in new audiences because
Amazon are going to be looking at a way
to attract new audiences they're not
going to want to rely on the old
audience because a lot of us
quite old
a lot of us are old they're going to
want to start a franchise and have new
people jump on board to that franchise
just look at like what Star Wars did
that's been going since the the early
60s
they have the old audience and then they
bought in the prequel trilogy that
brought in new audiences and then they
had the sequel Trilogy which brought in
even more of an audience and say what
you like about Star Wars that's kind of
how I reckon
Amazon will be looking at Stargate they
want to bring in a fresh new audience
but also kind of kind they're going to
want to please us as well they're going
to want to they're gonna need to because
we are the most vocal people because we
already know and we're already invested
in Stargate they're going to need to
please us first and foremost but they're
going to also need to
they're gonna have to attract new
audiences so how is it how how would
they be able to create a movie
that acknowledges everything that came
before it just how can you do it because
I can't honestly think of a way and this
is why I don't work at Amazon or MGM I'm
not that I'm not that creative I can't
think of a way for them to
create a story that makes sense because
what will more than likely happen if
Jennifer sulky got her way they had a
movie
uh before series and it came out in the
cinema which is what they they seem to
be wanting a cinema release okay
people are going to see Stargate in the
cinema there's going to be lots of news
articles about it Stargate is back the
second Stargate movie and there's going
to be people who have already watched
the original 1994 movie
but they may not have necessarily
watched SG-1 Stargate Atlantis Target
Universe they may not have watched any
of that but if it's a continuation how
are you going to explain 17 Seasons
worth of character building World
building events that happen the fact
that we now have ships we have bases on
other planets and have it make sense
because the jump from the 1994 movie to
a new movie as a continuation is so huge
that you can't explain all in one movie
and this is where I'm struggling how do
you connect the two how do you connect
the original 1994 movie to a new movie
but also acknowledge the 17 seasons in
between this is something I can't wrap
my head around I can't think of a way
that they can do this
and this is why I'm so worried about
there being a movie Yes a movie would
bring in a larger audience and we've
spoken about
um audience like mixing like you'll have
people who who watch the 1994 movie
people who have just watched sg1 and
then you have General sci-fi fans and
they're going to want to try and
interconnect those audiences as much as
possible to have as large of an audience
with whatever they do whether it's a
series or or a movie but
I just cannot think of a way for them to
do this in a good way
the most
the most logical scenario I can think of
is don't do a movie first yes it will
bring in more audiences and you have
probably a little bit more money to
spend on a series but
you can do a movie later on start with a
series start with something that we are
familiar with something that will tie up
Loose Ends
something that will establish a new
threat a new arc something that we can
sink our teeth into and then think about
maybe making a movie based on that
because if it's good enough
I feel if it's good enough and it gets
the viewing figures that it needs you
can make a movie from the series just
look what sg1 did they had started
Continuum there's Target The Arc of
truth yes it was on the on the tail end
of DVD sales and DVD sales went down and
they didn't make the the third film they
were meant to make but DVD sales mean
nothing anymore your streaming services
where you could literally drop a movie
and have it perform as well as if it
would perform in the cinema I don't know
my My overall opinion is I just want a
series to have to happen before a movie
although I would love to see a Stargate
movie in the cinema I just don't see a
way of it actually working but
let me know what you think as as the
audience as
listening to what I've just said all the
scenarios I've put forward what would be
the most ideal scenario for you can you
think of a way that they can make a
movie and also have it respect the 17
Seasons that came before it and have it
make sense for newer audiences I'd love
to know because I can't think of it
myself
and it would be interesting to see and
think actually yeah that that might work
and that might give me some more hope
for a movie
overall as I said the series coming
first from Mark Ferguson horcr that's
what we want that's what I want
then maybe think about doing a movie
after that but
let me know
if you are new to the YouTube channel
make sure you hit subscribe and press
the Bell notification so you don't miss
a single video also whilst you're down
there consider becoming a fully fledged
side tracker by hitting the join button
down below thank you so much for
watching and I will see you
next week
[Music]